i mean we have different views sometimes
we have different
things but that's my husband all signs
point to divorce for kim kardashian
and kanye west and now a source tells
e.t
when kim knew their marriage was done
for good i mean
like that's not stuff we put on social
media e.t soar says the reality star has
been
over kanye in a romantic sense for a
while
but loves him as the father of their
four kids and
doesn't want to embarrass or hurt him
quote her last real attempt to make
their relationship work was when she
flew to wyoming in july
and was seen crying in the car with him
after that
she just knew that she had to be done
for good
of course that emotional trip to wyoming
came after kanye's controversial run for
president
something that a second source tells e.t
caused a
huge divide between kim and kanye quote
she hated the fact that he was running
and didn't feel like he was putting
their family first
or fulfilling his family duties she felt
that his behavior was completely selfish
and it was one of the many things that
caused her to rethink their marriage
and that tear-filled visit to see kanye
at their family ranch
came after kanye revealed during a
political rally in south carolina
that he and kim talked about having an
abortion when she was pregnant with
their first child
north so even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to she stood up
and she protected that child
kanye west went on a subsequent twitter
rant of since deleted comments about his
wife
and her family i'm not gonna you know
just start
tweeting what my thoughts are but yeah
we have those moments
all that led kim to making a lengthy
public statement about her husband's
mental health
and kanye was quick to issue a public
apology to her
he's just the most genuine person
and you know he might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it
now e.t source says kim has reached her
limit at the end of the day
life is about being happy quote other
than the concern for her own family
kim takes her career businesses and
image very seriously
and keeps that in mind with all her
relationships and choices
kanye's actions have affected all
aspects of her life
kim's family supports her in any
decision she makes
and in everything she does i feel like
we are so blessed to have the best
support system and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through